[Música]
extienden el estado de emergencia en
Perú el gobierno decretó que a partir de
este domingo y durante 30 días la medida
también se aplicará a las regiones de
Lima y cusco el objetivo es controlar
las protestas que han dejado 49 personas
muertas
el clima extremo azota a Estados Unidos
el presidente Joe biden decretó la
alerta en California por las tormentas
que han dejado 19 personas muertas y
también en Alabama donde los tornados
dejaron Al menos nueve fallecidos
en el marco del aniversario número 31 de
los acuerdos de paz en El Salvador
cientos de personas salieron a las
calles para rechazar varias medidas del
presidente nayib bukele como el régimen
de excepción que ha provocado
detenciones arbitrarias y sus
aspiraciones de un segundo mandato
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Perú entró en vigor el estado de
emergencia decretado este domingo por el
gobierno y extendido hacia otras
regiones del país la decisión se debe a
las manifestaciones que no se debilitan
desde la destitución del presidente
Pedro castillo del pasado 7 de diciembre
con esta medida se autoriza al ejército
a intervenir para mantener el orden
durante 30 días en Perú los
manifestantes siguen exigiendo la
dimisión de la presidenta interina Dina
boluarte y la celebración inmediata de
elecciones ante esa movilización el
gobierno ha decidido extender el estado
de emergencia la presidenta de la
República decreta a partir del 15 de
enero de 2023 por el término de 30 días
calendario el estado de emergencia en
los departamentos de puno cusco Lima y
en la provincia constitucional del
callao la medida también aplica para
otras cuatro provincias y un Distrito
está autorizada al ejército a intervenir
para mantener el orden y conlleva la
suspensión de varios derechos
constitucionales como la libertad de
circulación y reunión y la
inviolabilidad del domicilio las
protestas estallaron a principios de
diciembre tras la destitución del
presidente Pedro Castillo acusado de
haber intentado perpetrar un golpe de
estado al querer disolver el parlamento
que se disponía a destituirlo desde
entonces los enfrentamientos entre
manifestantes y fuerzas de seguridad son
cotidianos y el país está de luto 48
manifestantes y un policía murieron la
Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos que visitó el país ha pedido a
la investigación la comisión recibió
denuncias de disparos indiscriminados en
contra de personas manifestantes en
ciertas regiones frente a estos hechos
la comisión Recuerda que el estado tiene
el deber de realizar investigaciones
serias imparciales y efectivas por su
parte la presidenta se niega a renunciar
en un un mensaje a la nación no asumió
ninguna responsabilidad en la violencia
de la represión contra los manifestantes
tras el intento golpista ha sucedido el
pasado 8 de enero en Brasil el
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva se
ha visto fortalecido luego de encontrar
el respaldo en la institucionalidad
brasileña la población civil e incluso
la comunidad internacional Mientras
tanto las investigaciones en contra del
expresidente bolsonaro aumentan y su
imagen se ve fuertemente afectada veamos
el análisis de Andrés triviño
Lula estaría sacando provecho de los
bochornosos sucesos del pasado 8 de
enero desde que empezaron las
investigaciones de los hechos todo
parece fortalecer al recién posesionado
presidente
de enero se ha puesto en una situación
bastante difícil Incluso en el ámbito
político
en personas políticas no han tratado de
demarcarse como en contra de lo que ha
sucedido la rápida actuación de las
autoridades logró que los ataques
vandálicos a las sedes del Congreso la
Corte Suprema y la presidencia fueron
controlados en menos de cinco horas un
hecho que produjo que miles de personas
salieran a las calles de todo el país a
manifestarse en contra del asalto
incluyendo la participación de
representantes estatales y legisladores
de todos los sectores políticos la firma
de atafolia señaló que el 93% de los
brasileños condenan los mientras que un
55% considera que bolsonaro estuvo
involucrado en los hechos a nivel
internacional organizaciones como la ONU
y la Unión Europea expresaron su apoyo a
Lula
incluso líderes conservadores que han
apoyado bolsonaru como el Primer
Ministro israelí Benjamín netanyahu y el
expresidente colombiano Álvaro Uribe
hicieron un llamado a respetar la
democracia
Parece ser que la extrema derecha en las
Américas No pues va perdiendo fuerza en
el sentido de que tuvimos a Trump en
Estados Unidos que ha salido del Poder y
además de eso pues está ahí también
enfrentándose a la justicia en Estados
Unidos y vemos en otros países de
América Latina la extrema derecha pues
perdiendo su espacio político no las
investigaciones en contra de bolsonario
continúan y más de 1800 personas han
sido detenidas entre ellas Anderson
Torres quien sirvió al ex mandatario
como suministro de Justicia una ficha
clave que podría empeorar la situación
para bolsonaro Nueva York se alista para
el juicio por narcotráfico contra el ex
secretario de seguridad de México Genaro
García Luna y el más importante desde el
juicio contra El Chapo Guzmán en 2019
este es el funcionario mexicano de un
alto Rango en ser juzgado en una extensa
persecución de Estados Unidos contra
narcotraficantes y su complicidad con
distintos gobiernos de América los
fiscales acusan a García Luna de aceptar
millonarios sobornos para permitir que
el cartel de Sinaloa enviara toneladas
de droga a territorio estadounidense
entre 2001 y 2012
los extremos climáticos tienen en
emergencia a dos estados de Estados
Unidos primero el presidente Joe biden
declaró la alerta para California el
sábado por las tormentas que han dejado
al menos 19 personas muertas desde
diciembre y el mandatario también
declaró la emergencia este domingo para
Alabama por los tornados que también
afectan a Georgia Andrés granadillo nos
cuenta más
entre inundaciones y tornados están los
estados de California y Alabama en
Estados Unidos los habitantes de
prattville en cercanías de Montgomery
recogen los escombros que han dejado los
destructivos vientos su casa ya había
sido devastada en un tornado anterior la
primera vez que nos golpeó fue el
Tornado f1 pero solo se llevó la casa
eso fue malo pero todavía tenía mi
negocio todavía podía ir a trabajar esta
vez tan pronto como salí Caminé
alrededor vi la tienda y todos mis
camiones de trabajo y herramientas
desaparecidas al menos seis personas
murieron el jueves en el centro de ese
Estado Sureño a causa de las tormentas
eléctricas y uno de los tornados que
azotaron la región
a mí me parece raro que esto ocurra más
en invierno Esta no es la típica
temporada de tornados así Que supongo
que mi mayor problema es el hecho de que
parece estar ocurriendo más a menudo
fuera de temporada
mientras en California lluvia fuertes
vientos e inundaciones han azotado el
estado desde de diciembre caitlyn dice
que no estaba preparada para que el agua
subiera tanto en estado de shock porque
a pesar de que nos preparamos para ello
no nos preparamos para que llegue Tan
Alto Como lo hizo por lo que fue más lío
más destrucción casi 23.000 hogares y
negocios se quedaron sin electricidad el
sábado en los dos estados el presidente
biden decretó el estado de emergencia
para ayudar a los habitantes con la
crisis agilizando el envío de ayudas
federales El Sistema Meteorológico da
una luz de esperanza y dice que el clima
cederá la próxima semana
organizaciones de la sociedad civil y de
diferentes comunidades de El Salvador
salieron a las calles de San Salvador
para conmemorar el aniversario de los
acuerdos de paz de 1992 que terminaron
Con 12 años de un conflicto armado que
dejó más de 75 mil víctimas en ese país
centroamericano los manifestantes
también rechazaron el régimen de
excepción que impuso bukele para
controlar a las pandillas y su intención
de correr en las presidenciales de 2024
la paz vuelve al debate organizaciones
de Derechos Humanos Víctimas de la
guerra grupos opositores y ex
guerrilleros conmemoraron el 31
aniversario de la firma de los acuerdos
de paz que terminaron con la guerra
civil salvadoreña de los años 80 un
aniversario sin actos oficiales ya que
el gobierno de nayib bukele no reconoce
la fecha por diferencias políticas
que los acuerdos de paz fueron una
cuando miles de personas murieron
fallecieron y existe impunidad en este
país de muchos casos que se dieron los
manifestantes rechazaron la intención de
reelección presidencial de bukele en
2024 y la imposición de un régimen de
excepción que según cifras oficiales ha
dejado más de 60.000 detenciones
criticadas por organismos de Derechos
Humanos
expresarme por las injusticias que se
están dando más que todo por la captura
de gente inocente Pues porque sin
antecedentes penales sin antecedentes
policiales no creemos en el hecho que
justifican estos
la fiscalía y el mismo gobierno de que
es procurar justicia Este no es un hecho
de procurar justicia Entonces nos
preguntamos Cuál es la verdadera
intención de estos hechos es claramente
un ataque y una venganza política contra
nuestros territorios organizados
los denominados acuerdos de paz de
Chapultepec en 1992 Fueron liderados por
Naciones Unidas y pusieron fin a uno de
los conflictos más sangrientos de
América Latina que dejó más de 75.000
Muertos hasta aquí este Informativo en
Francia 24 Gracias por acompañarnos
continúen con toda nuestra programación
[Música]